Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and today marks the four year anniversary of my time on this channel.
And coincidentally, today is also the day that I'm going to be hitting 13 MILLION subscribers on YouTube.
And that's... phenomenal. That's amazing. That's such an enormous number.
And to celebrate it, I have come up with a very stupid idea that I call the Fire and Ice Challenge challenge
I have thirteen habanero peppers right here
That I'm going to be eating, while I'm in this ice bath,
and then once I'm done with the peppers, I'm going to be React(TM)ing to an old video of mine,
it is actually the first time I ever had facecam
So, if you're ready? I'm not ready.
But, here we go! *mutters* I'm gonna have fire in my head and... gonna have blue balls.
It's my epic YouTube... robe. *queue sexual music* *sexual grunt*
That wasn't as epic as I thought it'd be..
This is a bad idea. (You don't say?!)  You catching that?
Seeing this glory... oh my God.
Okay, so I'm gonna start out with- I'm gonna try to eat four of them
at first just to get it out of the way
and then I'm gonna get in the bath and I'm gonna continually pop them down
I'm gonna try to get it quick
Uh.. If you can count
That's- that's 13 of them of various sizes.
Huh?
MATT: Do you want something in case you vomit, like a trash bag or something?
*mark.exe is processing* That's a good idea, *laughs* that's a good idea!
Are you ready?
MATT: Mmhmm.
MARK: Am I ready?
RYAN: Are you?
MARK: No, I'm not ready(wat?)
3... 2... 1...
NOM NOM
It is somehow OK
It is less OK
It is not OK
Okay, four down!
Okay, four down! Ngh!
*Grunts as he gets into ice bath*
*Grunts and yells*
It's such a weird combination of sensations!
*Grunts repeatedly*(chewing)
*Cries*(more chewing)
*Cries* (continues to chew)
*Grunting in short bursts*(still chewing)
*chokes a little*(really?)
*Grunting* (laxatives?)
*smelles something nasty and howls like a dog*
*Panting*
Heh! Heh!
*Screams* (manly scream)
*Screams*
*Short scream*
*Hyperventilating*
Oh hi milk
*Screams*
NOM NOM
Aah. Eh eeh eh!
It's so hot! You guys don't know it's so hot and so cold OHH IT'S THE WEIRDEST THING IN THE WORLD!
*Shouts twice* Oooooh- OOOooohoooo
Ah, I just have four more!
Ahhh I gotta get 'em down!
Heh ehe eheh heh
FURIOSLY MUCHES PEPPER
SPEED CHEWING
*Grunts*
MORE SPEED CHEWING
Ah, they're down, I did it! I did it!
Ohh god! Give me the phone! Oh, before I vomit! Where is it? *Grunts* I got it!
MARK(in video): Hello everybody and welcome back to the Amnesia custom-
CURRENT MARK: Oh my god.
I'm such a doof!
MARK(video): - up in the corner? It's me!
MARK: It's me! It's me!
MARK(video): -so you guys can see my looks of horror-
MARK: *Laughs* This was so long ago!
*Grunts repeatedly*
It was so long ago! *Wheezes, then laughs*
Oh my god!
*Moans*
Oh, it hurts so bad!
*Yells in pain*
*Panting*
*Screams*
(Mark's old video still playing in the background)
*Groans*
Oh my god!
*Laughing and panting*
*Moans*
HBLBLBLBL! HBLBLBLBL!
*Panting*
HABLEH! BLEH!BLEH! HAHHHBA!
Not saying much, in there and in here!
*Pant
BECAUSE I CAAAN'T!
WOOOOOO!
*Pants*
It's so- you don't know, there's so many sensations of pain,
unlike anything I've ever seen before in my life.
Four years, all led up to this moment in my life!
(Actually saying "Four years culminated into this one moment, where I'm in a bath tub eating thirteen habeneros!", but sounds incoherent)
*Soft panting, gradually becomes louder*
*Screams*
*Grunts*
BLEH! BLEH!
I can't do it, okay, I'm out, I'm out
*Grunting*
Gimme! *Grunt*
*Panting*
*Video on phone continues to play in background*
Oh, I'm so cold!
But I'm burning on the inside out.
*Groans*
(to Matt) What are you laughing at??
You friggin asshole!
MATT: No, I'm scared
MARK(video): Sounds good to me!
MARK: Oh, I need to keep reacting to me!
Man, this was a- this was a custom story for amnesia.
MARK(video): It's like tons of light but-
*Gargles*
MARK(video): Booyakasha! Hiyah! Get out of here!
MARK: *Sound of milk being spit out* Booyakasha??
*Little burp*
MARK(video): There's a lightning stone on that side and it's going to devil creep me out.
MARK: I'm creeped out by a lightning stone?
You guys- do you hear that?
MARK(video): Not scared at all, sooo brave... obviously
MARK: I remember that
MARK(video): Oh, ew, I hate that picture
MARK: I would cover everything up with a false sense of insecurity.
MARK(video): Get out of here. Ah! Ohh, why do I hate mannequins so much? Ughh
Current Mark: I used to hate mannequins... a lot. Still do.
Ugh, oh man.
MARK(video): *Shouts repeatedly at something* GET OUTTA HERE! GET OUTTA HERE! GET OUTTA HERE!
My good old friend the chair... Gonna get some-
MARK: I used to love the chair!
The chair was my jam!
MARK(video): Of course he did
MARK: Ugh!
Ugh, I'm gonna get out
*Sounds of water splashing* *grunts*
I'm alright, how you doin'?
I'll survive *Ryan says something indistinguishable at the same time*
That was bad...
Oh man, it was such a blind fury of burning.
I was trying my best to, like, say things,
but... every breath was like poison fire.
The ice was chilling everything below the waist so,
it was the weirdest mixture of sensations.
I've never had my brain assaulted with so many feelings before.
I am going to be paying for this later... holy shit.
Oh, bread. That's right, I had bread!
Just thank you guys so much for being with me for four years straight, and
really cool to see an old video of mine,
'cause, it's funny, I- *chuckles*
I look back and whenever I see an old video of mine
I instantly am taken to the time that I recorded it
I remember where I was in my life
and I remember, also
how... shy... I was in that video
You guys may not be able to tell, but...
or maybe you can tell
I was really nervous in that video.
And it's just really cool to see how far I've come as a person
and how far I've come out of my own shyness
And back then, like, I could, I, like-
Me going in front of a camera was amazingly brave
For me, not for anyone else, but for who I was at the time
I didn't talk to anybody.
I, I didn't go out.
I didn't have friends that I hung out with all the time.
I, I like-
I mean, I had friends, obviously, but, you know...
I- I was a very introverted person.
and to see that old me
and to be proud of, you know, the choices that I've made, and,
And to be proud of where I am,
*Laughing* even though it led to this bullshit here, but
it's- it's fun and,
It's- it's been a rewarding four years And I look forward to a lot more cool shit
So thank you for being with me for four years,
and thank you for 13 MILLION subscribers.
I'm gonna go before I throw up.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see *you* in the next video.
Buh-byeee!